honey nuts spices and then add a little
flour plus a few other ingredients that
Volta hyzer beats prefers not to divulge
every year the gingerbread baker comes
up with about 20 new recipes but one
he's making now however is a classic
it's a Nuremberg err and easily :
I just want to yell I've been working
here at Lakeland Schmitt for 25 years my
favorite recipe is the black elisa the
dough contains lots of cocoa and nuts
and it's covered in a thick layer of
chocolate you can really sink your teeth
into ryan bison crumbles visitors can
watch him at work through the window and
of course they also get to sample the
freshly baked gingerbread leave kuku
Schmidt make between two and three
million gingerbread cookies a day most
of them are shipped to customers all
over the world
but the Franconian city in southern
Germany has more than gingerbread to
offer it boasts a pretty old town with
half-timbered houses and lovely squares
the house where the painter Albrecht
Durer lived is a popular attraction as
is the old town hall which still houses
the local government
the castle is nuremberg sland mark and
it's vitae Heisler Beach's first
recommendation in the Middle Ages the
castle was one of the most important
royal residences of the Holy Roman
Empire the first structures were
constructed around 1,000 the castle grew
as more buildings were added over time
but ahyes abates shows us his favorite
views from the castle and shares a few
charming little details there's a story
behind this horseshoe mark the legend
goes that the famous robber baron Evelyn
fungi Lundgren was supposed to be hanged
here his last wish was to ride his
beloved horse one last time around the
square he seized the opportunity to
escape by having his horse jump over the
40 metre wall into the moat what is a
good line from the Middle Ages to
modernity vitae Heysel Bates's second
recommendation is the Museum of
industrial culture it's all about the
cities technical cultural and social
history from the 19th century to now
the museum is located in a former screw
factory where historical machines and
vehicles have been on display since the
1920s there's an impressive motorbike
election norm burg used to be a center
of the German two-wheeler industries he
fed me bisaya specially liked the
motorbike exhibition there are 130
vintage bikes including this triumph 250
my dad rode and now to total Martin's ax
or a flea market island on the river
pig-nuts the historical hangman's bridge
connects the island with the mainland
the water bridge and tower provide a
wonderful panorama for budding
photographers people executioner's used
to live here that's how the tower got
its name hangman's Tower it was seen as
impure profession so Nuremberg citizens
banished executioner's to the island
there was also a pig market on the
island but there's no trace left of it
instead there are now cafes and small
shops but to Haizlip II it's likes
coming here in the evening when there's
a romantic atmosphere from the lights on
the square
this is one of my favorite squares in
Nuremberg the island is characterized by
the nice small stores and the lovely
lighting it brings Christmas cheer love
you